this is really really breaking news I
don't know if you guys heard but there
is what's riding to the dentist right
now because I have to go back well I'm
in a car Jenna's driving me super upset
but she doesn't understand that I love
them they're called the spit would like
my freaking out and I understand I
understand and I just want to also
remind you and probably too late at this
point don't look at the Sun I glanced at
it very very briefly and it hurt my eyes
way too late it's a little be helping
now look you're live streaming from your
camera
I know I hear that it's very very
exciting event actually it's pretty
exciting
unfortunately here in LA you're only to
be able to see about 70% of the coverage
I'm going to be sitting in the dentist's
chair getting getting picked up you can
take we're very excited thank you so
much for driving this is shining on
example glasses when the pollution point
this is why there is an open appointment
because there was practically possible
intro I forget but this is history
what if I'm not around to the next one
your fault
you won't even know it's a pattern
you'll be looking down our new we
looking up somewhere Jenna will be
looking I'll see it waiting for more is
going to the day before going why we're
going to give back my doing I'm gonna
take some really amazing photos with my
iPhone and then I'm gonna show them to
you
I got this hard listen please like it
like I need this beautiful under if to
watch the Eclipse
hey we got
now
now I'm only following a card
okay I got it right my god it's not
going on
my record
nothing quality quality keep see
anything gosh I want my money back who's
gonna get the glasses was afraid through
all these scams on Amazon people selling
big glasses but they would actually hurt
your eyes if you use them so instead
you're just using no glasses and hurting
your eyes anyway no I'm using my camera
I'm looking at it with my camera I did
peek I thought yeah the shots are giving
me ha
my god let's borrow somebody's glasses
look everyone's having a good time here
we're gonna take Wiggy out I'm gonna
head up to go to my dentist appointment
using I'm here late if you'd like you
can hang out all those people or you
could be one of them you can borrow
their glasses and they could not leave
no one had lot there were like three
people
well I felt like I had intended off oh
hello Robin left booting it out not look
at the funny mentor now
Hey look phase is the Eclipse in right
now okay well 10:23 10:23 we got to see
it let's go with cool God look could you
take oh god glasses wow we miss out oh
wow yeah I'm seeing it
did we miss it did we miss it oh well I
think was like 70% right whoa oh cool
do you want me back oh thank you
Wow
I had much disappointment when or where
this is good for us I just like Mansa
here I'm going back inside like Mike
called Spitzer this is so cool you know
it's not almost like a moon you know
kind of you can kind of see it - the
glasses this is so much cooler than I
thought it was going to be to look is
that so cool yeah cooler than I kept
trying to take pictures in my iPhone I'm
like this looks like actual I guess
that's insane Bree oh yeah yeah
that was so cool I'm so thankful for
those my strangers that let us have
these glasses okay now I got it was done
right we're back at the dentist the
Eclipse was incredible and now I just
got the shock for the the novocaine
and then we pop off this temporary and
then I get my actual chrome on so that's
what's happening now
did you remember the x-ray we showed you
I do all right all right
total difference here just wait okay let
me show them guys we just got done I
survived fault gosh here's the hole that
was definitely that was a ridge a lane
and then the x-ray that we took today
and make sure the holes clean is looking
firmly now there's no glue on this one
mm-hmm
remember because we did it before you
thought you're cleaning but number that
black or so you are solid again there's
your containers what it was that was me
this one no that's the whole gone that's
why you want to get your teeth cleaned
every six minutes good extremely proud
we survived you sure well can you
believe it
very good great well I guess I'll be
back because I have some other things I
have to get done so thank you oh it
wasn't as bad as as I make it to see
[Music]
we out here in office so long because
did you know the caffeine use the
effects of novocaine and make it harder
to known I didn't know that was actually
really really cool so now home and I'm
gonna start editing the vlog that you
just saw got some things going on the
past couple weeks so I've been cleaning
and reorganizing my house and I decided
that I would to have this upstairs pages
because it's kind of like that move in
beige color is my least favorite however
without what I wanted was the light gray
which is what I wanted but this is blue
that's that's blue this is the colors I
originally it picked blue it's like a
baby blue color then L the air just came
on I need to clean that that's dirty so
now I'm heading back to my office which
is a mattress is in the middle here once
that other room is painted that will go
back in there with some of the furniture
that I ordered but I just go back from
Napa last week and it was actually
really fun I've never been to Napa and
there is something it's super cool most
people think of wine it's known
predominantly as being one country but
there it's a safari there I'm going to
show you guys a vlog that I filmed from
there and that's where I'm going to
leave you guys in today's vlog and also
an update on the tooth is feeling great
I'm so happy I even ate ice cream he
said it might be a little sensitive to
cold I guess what it wasn't I just had
to test I had to test to be sure that it
was going to be okay it was okay let's
go to Safari
[Music]
[Applause]
right now we're on this truck in Napa
going on a safari truck is starting up
girl look at amol finish up our driving
tour it was about like an hour and a
half and now actually might be longer I
feel like two hours of driving through
the forest and seeing all kinds of cool
animals now we're on the walking portion
and the best part about it is frozen
sangria and can bring it with you on the
tour kept you having fun yeah having a
great time you get your sangria you know
my sangria I'm in did you enjoy the
giraffe great traffic three week old
your ass
it was so cute I'm here we have some
finished sauces Sydney pastas are the
world smallest sauces they live in the
northern desert Sebastian
[Music]